mike fultonevich on the mound tonight
his fifth start with the rangers
16 hits a night ago for the angels their
highest total since
2019 as fletcher sends the ball into the
corner
and that's gonna bound up against the
wall garcia goes to retrieve it
and on a two-strike count david fletcher
has a lead-off double
it is jose quintano on the mound for the
angels tonight 32-year-old veteran
southpaw
now nick solak getting 286 five homers
and 12 rbis
quintana this one hit well center field
trout goes back to the wall
gone straight away center field where
the big boys hit him
sixth home run of the year for nick sola
and the rangers strike first tonight
well he went down and got that one what
a great swing
by solac i've seen him go deep to the
opposite field
[Music]
the 3-2 home got him swinging
and another fastball swung on and missed
a pair of first-inning strikeouts for
jose quintana
rangers on the board first however
one-nothing texas
walsh sends the ball into the gap in
left center field
[Applause]
fine played appearance and on a
two-strike pitch walsh has
the angel's second lead off double of
the game
albert homer yesterday his fourth in his
last
seven games
and albert lines it back up the middle
walsh coming around and the angels have
tied it at one a piece
albert comes through again
good baseball name though lined out
toward right field
and caught by gallow
another diving effort that was close oh
man joey gallo is always locked in
defensively
trout lines that one into left field
that scoots
past garcia and rattles around
mike's into second with the angels third
double of the ball game
there's a ground ball all up the middle
base hit
solac is two for two tonight
solace out there for joey gallo and
gallo again
batting with somebody on base
oh that ball hammered down the right
field line
and he's back a two-run
shot for joey galloway
the rangers lead it 3-1
that thing was a bolt oh man that ball
was crushed we got to run that one
back
2-2 and another strikeout
this time of upton and there are two
away that's another strike that's the
first of the night for fulton
the set by quintana and the 2-1 swinging
a hard-hit ball right side right in
front
of trevino and into right field of base
hit
trevino had to stop to let that ball go
by him didn't want it to hit him
so he stops at second base here as
willie singles to right he's now
three for eight against southpaw
pitching rangers have two on with one
out for charlie culberson
this ball well hit into left field by
culverson
around third base trevino the throw
off line and trevino in there to make it
a 4-1 game
[Applause]
white lined out on his first at-bat
tonight
calhoun at second culberson at first and
that one flared into right field base
hit
calhoun around third base they'll send
him to the plate no throw offered
rbi single by white it's five to one
[Applause]
steve seashek is a strike away from
stranding the bases loaded
and minimizing the damage at just two
here
biggest pitch of the night for the
angels on its way
got him swinging
[Applause]
a long inning but it sure could have
been worse two in the texas fourth
five one rangers
[Music]
and iglesias has the base hit through
the 5.5 hole
and that slashed past culberson another
base hit
iglesias and ben boom lining up
back-to-back singles and the angels have
something cooking in the fifth
first and second two outs for trout and
he swings and it's a ground ball into
the shift
sliding is kind of folefa he knocks it
down but has no play
and the bases are loaded the pitch from
fulton
and this one in the air out to right
field gallows
there so the angels leave the bases
loaded
in the fifth yeah a little sire relief
from fulton evac we're halfway there
five to one
ground ball third base culberson up
where he goes the short way to second to
force out walsh
and a nifty defensive play ends the
inning so king
doesn't allow that base runner to score
108 here in the bottom of the 7th nick
solac coming up
that ball smashed out to left field and
it
is gone just got over the other side
it's a two-homer game for nick solac
and the rangers lead 6-1
[Applause]
so like staying locked in
[Music]
oh two pitch bouncer up the middle could
be two counter philippa steps on the
back goes to first
double play and this one is over
a 6-1 rangers win and they can win the
series
tomorrow night